ننتقل الى غزه الان حيث انطلقت مسيرات
جماهيريه دعت اليها فصائل العمل الوطني
والاسلامي في قطاع غزه في المنطقه
الحدوديه شرق مدينه غزه تمديدا ورفضا
لمسيره الاعلام التي تنظمها الاحزاب
الاسرائيليه المتطرفه في مدينه القدس معنى
من غزه مراسلنا وائل الدحدوح وائل عن هذه
التجمعات والاستجابه لها والى اي مدى
اقتربت من هذه المنطقه الحدوديه
[موسيقى]
بالتاكيد مريم ما تزال الحشود والجماهير
تتجمع شيئا فشيئا تلبيه لدعوه الفصائل
الفلسطينيه التجمع في هذه المنطقه
الحدوديه لكن ربما ما تشاهدونه هنا هو ليس
المكان المخصص للمسيره هذه المنطقه تقترب
جدا من الحدود مع قطاع غزه وكما تشاهدون
الشبان او مئات الشبان والفتيه تمكنوا من
الاقتراب جدا من هذا السياج اشعل بعض
الاطارات المطاطيه والقوا الحجاره باتجاه
جنود قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الغير
ظاهرين للعيان حقيقه هم تمطرس على هذه
السواتر اذا كنتم تشاهدونها والمصور يسلط
الكاميرا عليها
من الناحيه الاخرى من السياج كمطرس خلف
هذه السواتر بين الفينه والاخرى يطلقون
وابل من الر بعض الشبان تمكنوا بالفعل من
الوصول الى السياج تماما وقاموا بتعليق
بعض او رفع بعض الاعلام عليه في حين البعض
الاخر يحاول الاقتراب شيئا فشيئا وحقيقه
من محاور مختلفه ومناطق متعدده في هذه
المنطقه الحدوديه الخطره ونحن على مدار
الساعه الماضيه ونحن نشاهد يعني قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي حولت هذه المنطقه الى
ما يشبه الكر والفر على اعتبار انها
استخدمت ايضا طائرات
الطائرات المسيره في عمليه القاء
القنابل الغاز باتجاه المواطنين
الفلسطينيين حتى في المناطق التي نحن
بعيدين نسبيا عن السياج لكن حتى في هذه
المنطقه اطلقت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بين الحين والاخر عدد من قنابل الغاز فيها
في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي هذه المقدمه ربما المسيره لكن
حقيقه المسيره مكانها الان تتجمع في
المنطقه الغربيه ربما تبتعد مئات الامطار
من المكان الذي نتواجد فيه او حتى من
مناطق التي تتواجد فيها الشبان يتجمعون
يحملون الاعلام الفلسطينيه وهم على وشك
الانطلاق من المخيم الاساسي وهو بالمناسبه
واحد من المخيمات الخمس التي اسستها القوى
الوطنيه والاسلاميه عام
2018 عندما انطلقت مسيرات العوده وكسر
الحصار من قطاع غزه وهذا واحد من هذه
المخيمات الخمس قباله مدينه غزه شرق مدينه
غزه الان المسيره ربما انطلقت بالفعل من
المخيم الاساسي
وواضح بان المشاركين فيها هي حشود كبيره
جدا من المواطنين الفلسطينيين بالفعل هي
على وشك الوصول الى هذه المنطقه لكن هذه
مقدمه
مقدمه المسيره وواضح بان ما زالت الحشود
في الميدان الاساسي او المخيم الاساسي
وهذا ربما يعبر عن حجم المشاركه وحجم
تلبيه المواطنين الفلسطينيين وانصار
الفصائل
الجماهير الفلسطينيه لهذه الدعوه من قبل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه ملاحظ ان هناك علم
واحد هي الرايه الوحيده المرفوعه من قبل
المشاركين في هذه المسيره وهذا كان لافتا
وربما من ضمن التعليمات التي ربما اذاعتها
الفصائل الفلسطينيه هنا نلاحظ نعشا او
نعشا رمزيا
يحمل علم اسرائيل وصوره بن جفير وربما
سيحاول الشبان احراقه خلال الدقائق او
اللحظات القادمه لكن في نهايه المطاف كما
قلنا هذه المشاركه الواسعه من قبل
الجماهير الفلسطينيه الان قاموا باحراق
فعلا هذا التابوت الرمزي الذي يحمل علم
اسرائيل وصوره بن جفير
في عمليه رمزيه لرفض بطبيعه الحال مسيره
الاعلام الاسرائيليه من جهه وايضا رفض
سياسات الوزير الاسرائيلي المتطرف بن جفير
الان ربما كثفت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
من عمليه اطلاق قنابل الغاز سواء باستخدام
الطائرات المسيره او حتى من خلال
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيليين الذين
يطلقونها ايضا بالبنادق من خلال مواقعهم
المنتشره على امتداد السياج وبالتالي نحن
راينا سيارات اسعاف عدد ضخم من سيارات
الاسعاف وايضا اعداد من الاطفائيات
الفلسطينيه رجال الشرطه ورجال الامن في
محاوله كما يبدو للسيطره على الموقف حتى
يعني ربما لا تنهار الموقف بشكل كبير ولكن
بالتاكيد يعني امام الجموع وامام هذا
هؤلاء الشبان ربما يعني رجال الامن لا
يستطيعون السيطره تماما على الموقف ونحن
نرى بالعين المجرده الان ان عدد من الشبان
من اكثر من مكان تمكنوا الان
قنابل الغاز
تصل الينا من اكثر من مكان حقيقه
والاوضاع تزداد سخونه شيئا في شيئا
وكثير من قنابل الغاز حقيقه اطلقت في هذه
الاونه امطرت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
المكان الذي نتواجد فيه
بقنابل الغاز
المسيله للدموع